une des questions la plus simple la plus
basique dans le monde du vin est aussi
controversé
comment définir la qualité
comment faire la différence entre un bon
vin et un vin qui est sublime juin est
ce que c'est la maturité une présence
d'acidité minéralité l'ensemble de tout
ça je vous assure que c'est impossible
de mesurer ni pouvait la différence
seulement le palais humains pourront
destinée ils sont tous universellement
frappé par vrai grand vin et même par
par la plaie et par le choeur ces vins
sont émouvants il avait de l'émotion et
vibre avec la vie et chaque cellule dans
nos cordes récent les vins les plus
mémorables et excitant on de la longueur
du caractère et gagnent en complexité
avec le temps ces vins sont peut-être
pas parfait d'une point de vue est
logique le plus strict c'est possible
qu'ils aient défaut c'est parce que pour
faire les vins qui sont profondément
touchant il faut laisser la place pour
les conflits la complexité de la nature
qui entraîne forcément des imperfections
je suis californie d'une californienne
de naissance et bourguignon d'adoption
aujourd'hui les vins de bourgogne sont
reconnus comme le modèle de 20 artistes
hinault qui est synonyme maintenant de
vin de luxe
pourquoi à partir du 11e siècle les
moines cisterciens ont commencé une
tradition qui dure
ils ont divisé les vignobles dans des
climats
ils ont utilisé les utiliser deux
cépages le pinot noir et le chardonnay
comme véhicule d'expression de terroir à
notre domaine amoureux saint denis les
vignes couvre une surface qui fait un
qui ne met pas un kilomètre donc
directeur est dedans il ya 51 climat
différentes qui peut être fait qu'ils
peuvent faire monté séparément et
revendiquer séparément
commercialisés séparément après une
période où nous avons tourné aux
innovations industrielles pour faire
face aux défis de l'agriculture
mécanisation engrais pesticides
herbicides fongicides
il y avait un vrai changement de voie
les vignerons commencé étudier la
possibilité d'une courage et les
défenses naturelles de la plante on
travaille on des soldes et les vignes
différemment en 2001 au lieu d'en
arracher deux vignes qui était vieux vy
rosé et peu productives nous avons
décidé d'essayer de les cultiver en
biodynamie alors il y à autant de
versions des bides en biodynamie qui en
a des pratiquants mais déjà il faut
travailler en biologique qui change
fondamentalement la proche du travail
par exemple le jour une vignerons
abandonne les glyphosate
au lieu de faire un passage dans les
vignes il faut entrer plusieurs fois en
tracteur et parfois le métier au fait qu
il est nécessaire de rentrer à pied
et puis auch et à la main en 2012
quand j'ai réussi à convaincre ma
famille en californie d'abandonner le
roundup
au lieu de payer 800 dollars pour
traiter nos vignes il nous a coûté 32
mille dollars pour la même surface
mon père était pas content alors ensuite
il faut abandonner le les fongicides
systémique ici en bourgogne c'est très
humide et on a une grosse pression 1012
dans deux abandonné les les fongicides
systémique c'est un risque
une plongée systémique
une fois qu'elle est appliquée à la
plante la plante la porte dans sa sève
donc les nouvelles feuilles qui pousse
son protégé et quand il pleut il reste
dans au contraire d'une produits
biologiques et justine produits de
surface mais cas par contre nous savons
aujourd'hui qu'il ay un simple buzz
et même la communication entre les
microbes organismes qui vivent autour
des racines et les racines les
micro-organismes compost la matière
organique
il les rendra la plante la plante pour
attirer ces micro organismes dont elle a
besoin et relâche du sucre qu'elle
produit dans ses feuilles
alors si elle contient une fongicides
systémique avec les sucres et relâchent
si les fongicides tueront des
champignons tuant le pont entre la terre
et la plante les bénéfices de l'éliminer
élimination des fongicides systémique et
herbicides sont prouvés il ya plus de
vers de terre plus de champignons plus
je partirai plus de matière organique
plus d'humilité
les plantes sont plus résistants aux
maladies et puis ils montrent moins de
signes de vie rose ça c'est prouvé qu'on
y passons à la travail en biologique et
biodynamique
mais passons un qualité de travail qui
ne peut pas être prouvé
il faut pas chercher à comprendre il
faut chercher à sentir en biodynamie
déjà on travaille on accorde avec les
calendriers biodynamique donc en accord
avec les mouvements du de la lune et des
planètes
la préparation ne plus qu'on eut répondu
et les cinq sens elle consiste à faire
mature et la bouse de vache dans une
corne de vache un endroit spécifique du
domaine pendant tout l'hiver
ensuite on prend un père de la bouse
naturel pour un million de départs de
l'eau et en biodynamie
cette solution ça te dit c'est à dire on
remue dans un sens dans un récipient en
cuivre jusqu'à devoir saxe se forme on
remue dans un autre sens jusqu'à un
vortex ce forum pendant deux heures
et cette solution on applique à la main
au moment favorable selon mes
calendriers biodynamique
et qu'est ce qu'il fait cette solution
qu'est-ce qui fait le 501
nous ne savons pas cette une
c'est une solution homéopathique
debbouze fermenté c'est une suggestion
une impulsion au sol qui soutient une
population microbienne diverses et
vivant revenons à nos hommes et nos
femmes qui applique cette solution à la
main dans les vignes aux jupes
oui désolé
en fait avant que l'on regarde cette
photo je vous demande de déplacer votre
attention de votre écoute votre ressenti
alors j'ai gâché un peu la surprise mais
c'est pas grave je vous demande de vous
observez votre réaction
vous êtes prêts voilà encore j'aime 12e
j'ai une deuxième chance aux yeux mais
une réaction pour la deuxième photo s'il
vous plaît vous avez senti c'est ça la
biodynamie c'est la joie
alors quand on fait travailler le sol au
cheval ou latente de l'herbe par les
moutons et bien on amplifie le vivant
dans l'ain vernement et les plantes
récente donc maintenant quand on revient
il revient à nos hommes et nos femmes
qui marchent à pied dans les vignes au
lieu de faire l'application autres
acteurs pourquoi il est sceptique qui
disent que la seule raison que la
biodynamie biodynamie fait est fait
c'est parce que nous sommes obligés de
descendre du tracteur et marché dans nos
vies mais voilà une belle principe plus
que nous approchons à la plante
mieux on l'obs observons ému mieux en
interprétant sa besoin nous entrons dans
une vraie relation intime et nous
travaillons mieux
cette c2 vink on a hésité à arracher est
vrai planté après deux ans et c'était
plus productifs et les sols étaient
visiblement amélioré prochain photo on
va in côté une vigne qui est cultivé en
conventionnel
et puis notre vie note à nous ils sont
même jour côte à côte et on voit à
l'oeil nu qui lie à le mou ce qui pousse
sur surface qui ne signe d'une seule une
seule morte
on voit qu'il sur les compacts et on
voit aussi les baguettes qui restent sur
le sol qui sont pas composté alors que
les deux villes ont été pré tailler un
moment avec les bouts de baguettes
blessés dans nos rangs grâce à la
biodynamie nous restons plus que jamais
les différences dues au climat que les
moines cisterciens cherché à mettre en
valeur et nous avons amplifié l'énergie
de vie dans le vent je trouve une
inspiration de plus en plus faut plus
fort dans des lits le principe de
terroir terroir consiste à trois
éléments un la terre nos climats
protégés de les conditions climatiques
du millésime
et toi l'homme l'ensemble de choix qui
fait l'homme qui cultivent les cadres
sociologiques et économiques dans
lesquels domaine viticole travail et un
émotionnel de chaque vigneron qui
travaillent dedans tout laisse son
empreinte énergétique terroir est un
écosystème et le mans fait partie les
choix qui fait la personne qui cultive
un parc non seulement les fans et les
fleurs mais nous savons aujourd'hui par
les avances en épigénétique
quel impact génétiquement la plante
terroir n'est pas fixée elle est
dynamique
c'est une danse
a21 l'arrêt culture début les
civilisations et quel plus beau symbole
de la civilisation que le 20 mai sans la
nature et bien le vin est mort il en
fallait deux à chaque étape de la
production
chaque fois que nous prenons le choix de
laisser inhabitée nannetti native au
bout du rang une leçon habitat pour les
insectes unif bénéficiaires chaque fois
que nous lançons une fermentation
indigènes partir sont annulés nous
laissons la place pour l'inconnu nous
laisse ma place pour que ce vin nous
émerveille la bcv 1 qui sont nés entre
l'agriculture et la nature sont les plus
sombres et plus expressifs et les deux
sont nécessaires
comme chaque enfant et elle avait sur la
tutelle du maire et du père il faut les
deux il faut la force créatrice et la
structure et ses vins ses vins il ouvre
la porte à la transcendance c'est pour
ça que le vin est souvent accompagnée à
nos célébrations et nos cérémonies
ils nous aident à sentir l'énergie de
vie qui nous lie tous du cosmos à la
terre d'une équipe de production au
consommateur final
ils nous aident à sentir l'union qui est
notre retard
le plus naturel merci du genre